[Musique]
un pont flambant neuf pour irpine
ancienne ville martyre le symbole de la
renaissance personne n'a oublié ces
images elle raconte les premiers jours
de la guerre en février
2022 des habitants qui tentent de fuir
hpine boucha leur cité bombardée pour
rejoindre Kief le béton du pont comme
seul refuge Tatiana blisnuk était l'une
de ces silhouettes désespéré elle
accepte de revenir devant l'ancien pont
détruit par les Ukrainiens pour empêcher
l'avancée des rus sur la capitale il est
conservé comme mémorial à côté du nouvel
édifice c'est la première fois que je
reviens ici depuis le jour où c'est
arrivé j'avais tellement peur pour
atteindre le pont on a dû avancer sous
les bombes on a fait le parcours à
genoux c'était affreux encore maintenant
quand je regarde ces ponts le nouveau et
l'ancien j'ai la vision des
explosions un pont chargé de douleur
4 habits sont en le traversant sur le
nouvel ouvrage construit par une
entreprise tur le maire de la ville lui
aussi se souvient mais il préfère penser
à
l'avenir ce P fait désormais partie de
notre histoire ici on a évacué plus de
40000 habitants c'est le pont entre la
mort et la vie c'est pour ça qu'on
l'appelle aujourd'hui la route de la vie
on aonstruit le plus vite possible les
ouvriers ont travaillé jours
sur reconstruire et que c'est encore
mieux
qu'avant traverser le pont et rejoindre
le centre d'irpine c'est entré dans un
chantier à ciel ouvert et être hé par le
bruit des
travaux la ville est détruite ou
endommagée à 70 % participer à sa
reconstruction pour tous ses ouvriers
c'est plus qu'un emploi c'est un acte de
résistance j'en suis fier et j'accepte
même de travailler tous les jours alors
qu'avant je refusais les chantiers
partant de neige
on fait le maximum pour que les gens
rentrent chez eux et pour qu'il nit plus
de trace des Russes
ici en attendant les nouveaux logements
voici un quartier provisoire construit
avec l'aide de la Pologne des
préfabriqués où se sont installé 160
familles on y retrouve Tatiana blissnuk
ameublement minimal aucun objet
personnel juste des photos de son mari
mort après s'être engagé comme
volontaire la vie de Tatiana et de ses
deux enfants reste suspendu
c'est difficile je n'ai rien installé
car on ne sait pas ce qui peut arriver
demain il y a toujours ces attaques de
missile et on a peur à chaque alarme je
vais aux abris avec mes enfants et on se
demande si on va rester vivant c'est
encore très
stressant la réouverture du pont
d'irpine est particulièrement symbolique
en ce moment un peu d'espoir alors que
la contreoffensive patine que le froid
s'installe durablement sur le pays et
que le moral des Ukrainiens est
globalement en berne